une journée pour célébrer un bout à
l'autre du pays
mais pandémie oblige plusieurs
cérémonies sont en ligne cette année la
journée nationale des peuples
autochtones se déroule dans un contexte
singulier on était moins depuis quelques
semaines de situations qui sont
hautement préoccupante chez nous et qui
qui est quand même très certainement qui
laisse place à la colère
au cours de ces dernières semaines des
vidéos ont fait surface montrant de la
violence policière contre des
autochtones comme celle de l'arrestation
du chef adam en alberta où ces images
d'un véhicule de la grc qui font sur une
inuit et le frappe avec la portière
ouverte 8 autochtones sont morts au
cours des trois derniers mois en lien
avec une intervention policière
chantal mort et ronny levy sont les deux
derniers en lice il ya eu plus de
victimes aux mains de la grc à trois
mois qu'il ait eu de victimes dans nos
communautés de lakovic donc les gens
chez nous en plus par des virus
pourrait-il y avoir une prise de
conscience dans la population digne du
mouvement black live marne et aux états
unis
le chirurgien innu c'est un lit volant
le souhaitent
malgré tout aujourd'hui nonobstant tout
le respect que j'ai pour mes soeurs et
mes frères noirs
ça fait 50 ans qu'on subit la
colonisation la pression des autorités
mais je pense qu'il faut aussi affirmé
en cette journée on ne tolère plus de
pertes de vies selon ghislain picard
les solutions sont connues il faut
maintenant agir à cette commission assez
d'études en anneau pour tapisser les
murs d'une maison complète
tout était dit je pense que le prochain
geste plutôt c'est de penser à l'action
comme bien d'autres chefs autochtones
il attend des gestes concrets de la part
des gouvernements départ essentiel pour
rebâtir la confiance qui ne cesse de
s'effriter
il s'y fait de vincent foisy radio
canada ottawa